[Music]
oh you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care auditor stronk eyes
beautiful girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again
kiss me like you miss me read what in
the ass
my name is cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid movie guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be you need you lot smarter
than I look
I let cable kill this kid I can't do
this alone
we're gonna form a super duper group
that's what we're gonna be
forward-thinking gender neutral you will
be known as x-force a little derivative
you're absolutely right now cue the
music don't call it a comeback
tell me they got that in slow motion
doing the right thing is messy
you want to fight for what's right
sometimes fight dirty
that is why the man bun is just a
millennial mullet oh oh god I wish I
finished college it lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it I was born into war right
into it people think they understand
that but they have no concept of it
what's the most pain you've ever felt
maybe the kind that leaves you more
machine wait does that deal what why why
are the visual effects not done it's a
metal arm it's not like we're trying to
remove a mustache oh I'll do it myself
I'm cable and I'm from the future and
I'm always pissed off oh no sheriff
Deadpool you know you're a lot taller in
the shut up
grunt grunt take this regeneration
powers activate that's not something
says cable I got the stuns to help you
no biting they're done already
oh wow that was unrealistically fast
okay
[Music]
your time's up dumbass
well that's just lazy writing ah
[Music]
Brazil the beautiful sunkissed home of
Pele hairless genitalia and the world's
largest Jared Leto statue to show my
dedication to the legions of Brazilian
Deadpool fans
I've spent up to 20 minutes on Google
Translate as well as countless hours
watching telenovelas to teach me
everything about your official language
that's right but I see you this sexy red
spandex task learn to speak Portuguese
all right hopefully I get the accent
right here goes my second o KO punah
circus ain't Princeton RAC so annoying
heritage SEO nuna Comic Con Brazil
vermin Darmstadt Oh odorous my so milena
dos proseccos poo nukemama bella terra
de segura shares cinta de leche Volgin
sapelo Co Co Co Co MA Shakira in Quebec
CEO Jeffrey Suraj ma la parte de que voy
a comprar dementia gratis innovate Costa
nada assassin our own contrato de
defensa se prepara regard Rai Bachchan
new Baku mahjong Falacci of science
porque Hamada season 5 cocoon gossip
resembling a mo mo mo mo kio temple ami
among GData eden samba pelon
familia specific event a swan mine Karen
elephant butakov father my own Gullu
Pella so pi ish it's a my off to do to
discuss a song modelers presume suggest
Oprah made a vase or Chima
I went to Vassar Mizuki be don't tap
another Enya you discussed Majorca look
me straight in the nipples and tell me I
didn't just nail that now what are you
waiting for go to the website below to
reserve your spot and you're sure to be
the talk of South Paulo space is limited
so best hurry because I think we can all
agree there's nothing like a wild day or
night in Brazil to make a special memory
that you'll cherish her
just ask the 2016 US men's swimming team
they'll probably make some [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
I've worked so hard in this lifetime
let's go you want to end up not on my
watch [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's like six it layered no okay
so just don't wait call thank you Wow
nice suit
[Music]
oh Jesus
oh that's not good no no no oh you're
not gonna walk that one off oh that's so
gross
oh I'm so sorry
all right I spent way too long in the
phone booth but for being honest with
myself I probably should have just
called 911 well you're both is the real
point here [ __ ] is a phone booth doing
on a street corner those disappear in 98
huh
suppose they could have just used my
cell Jerry Garcia ice cream you can eat
this don't answer now mr. s I'm actually
I made a call to the costumer his name
is Larry usually helps me put the suit
on
I don't know how the other guys do it so
quickly you probably wouldn't be dead if
it was Logan he got to change into there
was a [ __ ] tank top and a pair of
jeans yeah walk to get my tank top on
bit of inspiration have a nice little
crime fighting spree yeah happy hugger
call a day
[Music]
hello there welcome back I'm glad you
could join me today let's just dive
right in and learn all the colors across
the screen that you'll need to paint
along with me I have my regular old
canvas here wet and ready to go now
let's grab our trusty 2 inch brush here
whack that off a little bit just feel
like it owes you money we're gonna get a
little damp or yellow snow here mix that
with just another little dab of our baby
hot now well that's just dancin happy
little say I remember this is your world
you get to make and break the rules here
sweet baby Jesus wish I could jump in
there and roll around and all that
cascading white powder yeah just get
high and all of life's splendor god I
love cocaine so much
holy [ __ ] knuckles I am high as a kite
right now ok let's paint in a few little
happy trees there nothing wrong with
making friends with trees no what you
don't want to do is eat these paints
trust me on this one alright I'm gonna
whack off again that's right that feels
good
[Laughter]
would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours
keep your pads dry your dreams wet and
remember hugs not drugs
[Music]
[Music]